[Musica]
e da venti minuti che mi chiedo cosa
abbia fatto di male a mattia per farmi
parlare dopo renzo piano deve essere
stato grave probabilmente avevo rubato
la prima fidanzata quella queste ditte
rimanere legati per tutta la vita
sono un urbanista sì lo so cosa pensate
dagli urbanisti
vi prego non non scegliete questo
pomeriggio per smettere di essere
politicamente corrette ditemelo
ditemelo con sensibilità vi parlerò come
ha detto mattia vedi città aumentate e
sono contento di parlarne oggi qui a
rimini non soltanto perché oggi è il
giorno del primo dai di rimini questo ed
ex rimini così intenso così interessante
vulcanico con diversi registri diversi
linguaggi ma anche perché rimini oggi è
un giorno speciale lo sapete meglio di
me si apre dopo 70 anni il teatro galli
ed è una bella notizia per la città una
città in cui si riapre un teatro è una
città felice una città che ha
propensione attenzione verso il futuro
i pareo di città aumentate di quelle che
io chiamo città del diverso presente
però primo un'avvertenza le immagini che
state per vedere sono per un pubblico
adulto responsabile informato e
orientato al cambiamento metteranno in
dubbio le vostre certezze le vostre
consuetudini qualcuna discuterà per
alcune di esse penserete che non che non
riguardano la nostra quotidianità che
sono forse un sini che forse frutto
della mia immaginazione chissà dove le
ho trovate in giro per il mondo
e invece no tutto quello che vi farò
vedere reale esiste è già il presente di
altri di noi gli altri che vivono in
modo diverso le città un presente che
che ci interessa che mi interessa da
urbanista ci interessa da persone che
vogliono riappropriarsi della strada per
il futuro del futuro perché come diceva
ray kurzweil il miglior modo per
immaginare un futuro migliore lo diceva
inventarlo io dico e progettarlo cioè
riappropriandoci della nostra strada per
il per il futuro benvenuti quindi
del neo antropocene ma ora vi dirò di
che si tratta una prima domanda se l'è
fatta recentemente roger waters nella
copertina del suo ultimo disco è
veramente questa la vita che vogliamo
vivere is this is the life and really
want perché la domanda che ci anima e la
domanda che muove me da urbanista da
progettista delle città e la domanda che
muove molti amministratori cittadini
responsabili in vari in vari modi delle
della vita delle città ma quale quale
vita di quale vita ci dobbiamo
interrogare vogliamo andare verso uno
dei tanti futuri distopici che ci
racconta al cinema letteratura queste
reti player one di steven spielberg che
racconta questa città fatta con una
specie di bricolage di città dove si
vive in spazi angusti uno sopra
all'altro senza nessuna qualità ma ne
potremmo utilizzare tanti altri oppure
questa questa invasione della tecnologia
che però non sempre ci ha fatto
diventare più intelligenti un po come
questa vecchia pubblicità della apple in
cui sembrava che il nuovo macintosh per
forma così si chiamava avrebbe reso più
intelligenti anche i babbuini allora
questo però è la vita che io vi invito
cominciare a ripensare vedete questa
immagine rappresenta il mondo deformato
in cui continenti sono deformati in
funzione di due fattori
l'impronta ecologica cioè quanto pesiamo
sul pianeta e la perdita di identità
culturale quando guardiamo noi stessi
quando guardiamo il mondo attraverso
questi due parametri ahimè il mondo
occidentale l'europa l'italia la vedete
lì al centro a questo è un triste
primato
siamo tra i primi paesi al mondo per
perdita di identità culturale e per
estensione per pesantezza dell'impronta
ecologica il 20 per cento del pianeta è
composto da città il 53 per cento delle
persone al mondo vive in città in europa
l'ottanta per cento negli stati uniti
l'ottanta per cento
il l'estremo oriente sta andando
velocemente questo risulta
queste città dove si concentra la
popolazione producono l'ottanta per
cento delle emissioni di co2
siamo i responsabili con la nostra
quotidianità indipendentemente a quello
che facciamo
indipendentemente dal da quello che
produciamo la nostra vita quotidiana
produce l'ottanta per cento delle
emissioni di co2 questo è quello che si
è stato definito da due straordinari
scienziati stoermer crutzen
l'antropocene partito nella con la
rivoluzione industriale è arrivato
rapidamente ai tempi che viviamo con una
pesantissima responsabilità dell'uomo
sul pianeta qualcuno arriva a dire che
forse siamo noi gli intrusi al pianeta e
che se il pianeta è malato siamo noi i
responsabili
qualcuno addirittura ritiene che la cura
sia la nostra sparizione ma io non mi
arrendo
perché non siamo solo quello le nostre
città e guardate quanto ulteriormente
l'europa e l'italia si ingrandiscono
prendono corpo quando la quale guardiamo
attraverso altri due fattori nelle città
è vero che si produce 80 per cento di
co2 però si produce la maggior parte del
prodotto interno lordo lo so il prodotto
interno lordo non è una misura adeguata
e sufficiente per il nostro benessere
però non misura che ci permette di
capire alcune cose una misura che ci
permette di comparare situazioni nelle
città si produce una componente
importante del motore di sviluppo e di
benessere
ma ancora più importante è che in europa
l'ottanta per cento delle industrie
creative e culturali
quindi della ricchezza del valore
prodotto dalla cultura da eventi come
questo da tante altre iniziative
attività la riapertura più tardi del
teatro galli e prodotto nelle città sono
siamo contemporaneamente viviamo
contemporaneamente in luoghi che
emettono gas nocivi per il pianeta ma
anche siamo viviamo in un luogo che è
capace di compensare questa emissione è
quello che io chiamo urbano scene
l'energia creativa e innovativa delle
città alla dobbiamo scoprirlo questo
diverso presente perché noi dobbiamo
trovare una soluzione tra questi due
estremi tra l'essere degli invasori
della bellezza salubrità felicità del
pianeta
terre di essere anche coloro che lo
strillo hanno arricchito della nostra
intelligenza della nostra sensibilità
dobbiamo andare ad un'altra velocità
talvolta rallentando talvolta
accelerando come ci hanno fatto vedere
gli amici che mi hanno preceduto
dobbiamo essere i protagonisti la
rivoluzione del neo antropocene lasciamo
stare il paleoantropologo che è iniziata
la rivoluzione industriale
se è vero che l'uomo è l'essere che più
di altri interviene sul pianeta
uomini e donne siamo anche noi con le
nostre sensibilità con le nostre
intelligenze
io non mi arrendo essere consigliato
soltanto un e roditore di risorse un de
predatore di di qualità una persona non
sensibile se siamo qui se non ci siamo
alzati subito dopo le avvertenze vuol
dire che crediamo che possiamo anche
essere uomini diversi uomini e donne
diverse in questo pianeta e quindi
essere protagonisti di un nuovo
passaggio un neo antropocene questo ne
antropocene già esiste lo viviamo lo
attraversiamo e la nostra quotidianità
ed è fatto di quattro rivoluzioni più
piccole e vi faccio vedere rapidamente
perché le viviamo la prima è la
rivoluzione della società reticolare
della società rete della società aperta
della società delle connessioni dello
scambio della della conoscenza di quello
che accade in altri posti
e questa rivoluzione ha aperto molto le
nostre possibilità le nostre sensibilità
la seconda la rivoluzione digitale è
stato ne abbiamo parlato spesso questa
questo pomeriggio la rivoluzione che ci
ha fatto diventare una società della
conoscenza in cui la conoscenza è non
solo merce preziosa e anche risorsa
preziosa energia preziosa ci permette di
essere consapevoli nelle scelte
sensibili capaci di selezionare e capaci
di agire
e poi ancora la rivoluzione ecologica la
consapevolezza che siamo di fronte a un
cambiamento climatico di cui siamo
irresponsabili ma forse possiamo essere
anche i risolutori come questa
straordinaria installazione alla
biennale d'arte dell'anno scorso a
venezia queste mani che escono dalla
e che ci dicono che forse dobbiamo
essere noi un po a reggere i palazzi
minacciati dall'innalzamento è che ci
sia il cambiamento climatico è una
evidenza a cui tutti noi crediamo e
siamo convinti e non c'è negazionista
che tenga quello strano personaggio che
capelli arancioni che governa gli stati
uniti e che ritiene che non esista la la
il cambiamento climatico è sicuramente
in un errore e vi farò vedere più avanti
perché e poi l'ultima rivoluzione la
rivoluzione creativa quella che io
chiamo il metabolismo circolare questa
che vedete la barriera corallina la
barriera corallina e nel mondo
il luogo con il più alto tasso di
creatività il luogo con il più alto
tasso di biodiversità nella barriera
corallina non esiste scarto non esiste
rifiuto tutto è utilizzato ogni specie
vivente è la barriera corallina è in
simbiosi con un'altra è un meccanismo
perfetto e per questo ha il più alto
tasso di biodiversità
per questo al più alto dal tasso di
creatività e noi dobbiamo somigliare
sempre di più alla barriera corallina
corallina meno scarti meno rifiuti più
collaborazione tra le specie e tra le
componenti
si comincia a parlare di di umanità
aumentata l'umanità che vive quelle
quattro rivoluzioni e una comunità è una
umanità aumentata ne parla alessandro
baricco nel suo ultimo libro the game
che vi consiglio libro interessante
perché si interroga sulla sulla
tecnologia e le città in cui abitiamo
se siamo diventati o stiamo diventando
vogliamo diventare una comuni una
umanità aumentata le città che sono il
substrato della nostra vita come sono
saranno le smart city le città adatte
per la umanità aumentata no sono un
idolo
troppo spesso si stanno manifestando
come un idolo come il monolite nero di
2001 odissea nello spazio
adorate riescono a individuare alcune
soluzioni ma non sono la soluzione
qualcun altro dice ma no sono le
cosiddette pensi
le città del turismo degli eventi degli
avvenimenti e ce ne sono tante in italia
palermo 1 dic western rimini sicuramente
un'altra ma anche queste sono una droga
come in una fumeria d'oppio finito
l'effetto dell'evento spesso torniamo
come prima certe volte più tristi ci
hanno illuso di una parvenza di vitalità
e quante città abbiamo visto esplodere
durante un evento durante un grande
evento un'iniziativa durante un festival
e poi però sono tornati i problemi o non
sono mai sparite non soltanto nascosti
davanti a quelle quattro rivoluzioni
davanti al fatto che siamo diventati una
c una umanità aumentata qual è la
risposta dell'urbanistica tradizionale
qual è la risposta dei miei colleghi
della mia disciplina di coloro che le
pro queste città le progettano e
progettano con voi e per voi questa non
si è spento il proiettore è questa la
risposta dell'urbanistica tradizionale
nessuna quantomeno non ho una risposta
adeguata anzi una risposta c'è ed è
fermo al xviii secolo
ve lo ricordate questo l'esperimento di
luigi galvani 1792 pensava che le gambe
delle rane morte dissezionate
riprendessero vita attraverso il
passaggio di una corrente elettrica ci
ha creduto per un po di tempo poi ha
capito che non era così
ma su questo la letteratura costitu
capolavori tutti ricorderete il
frankenstein di mary shelley noi
urbanisti abbiamo pensato in buona
compagnia che questa fosse la soluzione
ogni volta che pensavamo che una città
stesse per morire o fosse morte in
alcune sue parti ecco la soluzione
tenerci esterna risorse pubbliche
iniziative estemporanee grandi progetti
o intermediazione politica malaffare
vengo da una regione che non c'è dubbio
che spesso ha trovato nel malaffare
l'energia esterna per risollevare le
città luigi galvani sera accordo
poco dopo che quella non era vita
era una parvenza di vitalità noi
urbanisti ci siamo accorti molto tardi
qualcuno non se n'è ancora accorto
allora abbiamo bisogno di un salto di
paradigma dobbiamo cambiare non possiamo
continuare ad illuderci che quella sia
una risposta da dove prendiamo l'energia
esterna da dove la deprediamo spesso
l'abbiamo presa dall ambiente dal
pianeta da altre da altre situazioni io
la risposta l'ho data e la mia risposta
non è la verità è la mia parziale
risposta nel post su cui sto lavorando
su questo
facendo approfondimenti sperimentazioni
si chiama città aumentata se dobbiamo
dare spazio luogo forma alla umanità
aumentata serve una città aumentata io
ho definito di migliorato queste dieci
componenti una città che usa i sensori
una città open source che è codificata
costruita e programmata insieme agli
abitanti e non soltanto dai tecnici o
dal o dagli amministratori una città
intelligente una città che torna essere
produttiva e non soltanto una città di
servizio una città di eventi una città
che torna a essere parte della economia
forse della nuova economia del mondo in
cui viviamo una città creativa una città
che ricicla come la barriera corallina
la città resiliente più fluida
soprattutto quelle che hanno un rapporto
intenso con il con il mare una città a
rete fatta di tante componenti che si
connette ad altre città e non non pensa
e ragiona persona da sola è una città
più strategica la città aumentata però
non è la città del futuro non è la
distopia di 1984 di orwell e la città
del diverso presente perché i tempi
stanno cambiando
com'era come cantava bob dylan e che i
tempi stanno cambiando ce lo dice questo
grafico questo è la sfida dell'europa
che mi piace dell'europa che ci piace
quell'europa che individui obiettivi
importanti quell'europa che insieme può
diventare un sistema di nazioni se non
una nazione che si pone obiettivi
importanti
entro il 2050 dovremmo ridurre dell 80
per cento delle emissioni di co2
quindi riducendo quella impronta
ecologica che vi ho fatto vedere a linea
dell'ottanta per cento stiamo avendo
difficoltà come sapete raggiungendo il
2020 la riduzione del solo 20 per cento
ridurlo dell'ottanta per cento significa
come vedete che non c'è attimo secondo
della nostra vita nelle città che non
dovrà essere modificato cambieremo il
modo con cui produciamo energia il modo
con cui ci muoviamo il modo con cui con
cui costruiamo le case in cui abitiamo
il modo con cui utilizziamo l'acqua i
rifiuti
qualsiasi cosa tutto cambierà questa è
la grande sfida cambierà anche
l'agricoltura la città aumentata
amplifica l'intelligenza umana potenza i
sensi talenti e gli abitanti come fa la
realtà aumentata
non è una realtà virtuale non è una
città virtuale quella capi racconto è
una città vera fatta della nostra
quotidianità del nostro mare del nostro
paesaggio delle nostre nostri centri
storici però capace di darci qualche
potere in più a partire dal talenti
delle passioni dalle volte ti farò
diventare un quartiere in cui potessero
vivere dignitosamente in edifici ben
fatti ben costruiti adatti
la comunità di migranti di amburgo tutto
questo utilizzando dei dispositivi
tecnologici intelligenti mettendo
insieme pannelli solari e un bio bio
digestore ad alghe che aumenta la
capacità del dl del pannello è ancora
nel 2004 già friburgo aveva costruito un
quartiere che produce quattro volte
l'energia di cui ha bisogno
ma voi lo immaginate la comunità
il sindaco di una città in cui c'è un
quartiere che produce quattro volte
energie di cui ha bisogno
una comunità più felice forse anche più
facile governarla perché una parte di
questa energia servirà l'edificio avete
tre parti di energia con cui fare tante
cose ma potete trasformare in soldi e
quindi distribuirle portarla lì dove non
avete possibilità di generare le stesse
stessi fattori potete regalare potete
mettere illuminazione pubblica che non
vi costerà nulla alla comunità la potete
regalare ai possessori di auto
elettriche che quindi saranno
incentivati
a passare all'elettrico tante cose si
possono fare in una città con un
quartiere che pose quattro volte
energetico ha bisogno oppure sensori
concludo con questa con questo stimolo
che è figlio anche di questa giornata
meravigliosa di tex rimini
siate divergenti siamo divergenti ma
dobbiamo anche imparare a coltivare la
convergenza la collaborazione e la
visione comune grazie ad azioni
[Musica]
no